match each function to its interval as
it appears on the graph below there will
be functions and intervals left over
when you are finished since we have this
crazy-looking graph here and what we
want to do is think about what
expressions define the different parts
of this graph so if we thought if we
thought for example that in the interval
between where X is greater than or equal
to 3 and X is less than 7 that this is
being defined by 1 over X we would drag
this into that just like that so to help
us think through it I've copied and
pasted this thing onto our scratch pad
and just let's let's go interval by
interval so this starts at X is greater
than negative 4 not greater than or
equal to or we could say it starts at
negative 4 is less than X not less than
or equal to because the function is not
defined at negative 4 we have an open
circle here but let's see what a good
candidate expression is for this part of
the function so to do that let's just
find some nice well-defined points here
so it looks like we have the point that
point over there is the point negative 2
comma looks like 1/2 we have the point
here which is negative 1 comma 1 and
those look like two good ones so let's
see which of these seem to work at least
for those points maybe we can rule out
some so 1 over X so let's see if we if X
is negative 2 1 over X would be negative
1/2 not positive 1/2 so this isn't you
being used to define this first section
so we can rule that out for at least the
first section now let's see negative f
of X is equal to negative 1 over X now
this looks pretty good negative 1 over
negative 2 is positive 1/2 so it works
for that negative 1 over negative 1 is 1
so this this right over here seems to
work for at least this interval so it
seems to work we're doing negative 1
over X and it seems to work even after
that where if you took negative we have
the point right over here 1 negative 1
negative 1 over 1 is negative 1 and over
here you have 2 negative 1/2 which is
also consistent with this right over
here so I would throw this one and
and so this function so this function
works from the interval negative 4 is
less than X which is less than or equal
to 2 so that's this interval that's this
interval right over here so let's
actually fill that in so that is that is
this inter actually you can't see it
it's off the screen right now and that
is that interval right over there now
let's go get back to my little scratch
pad now our function is not defined for
X between 2 and 3 but then starting at 3
the function gets defined again let's do
the same thing let's look at some
interesting points that might prove
valuable so this point right over here
actually we do it in magenta you have at
this point which is the point 3 negative
2 you have this point right over here
which is interesting 5 comma 5 comma 2
so let's test some of these points out
and see which of these work well 1 over
X definitely doesn't work 1 over 5 is
not 2 negative 1 over X doesn't work
negative 1 over 5 is not 2 1 over 5
squared is not 2 1 plus 1/2 times 5 plus
5 to the third power that's 10 to the
third power that's a thousand times 1/2
this 500 it goes to 500 to not 2 so
we're gonna rule this one out too so let
me rule it out for this for the interval
that we now care about we now care about
this interval or this part of the
function let's see if we have five-year
5 minus 5 is 0 to the third power is
still 0 times 1 half is still 0 plus 2
is 2 so this point is consistent with
this function 4 right over here now
let's see does that work for 3 negative
2 3 minus 5 is negative 2 to the third
power is negative 8 times 1/2 is
negative 4 plus 2 is negative 2 so this
looks like a pretty good this looks like
a pretty good candidate let's just try
to see if we make sure we can rule this
one out too well see 5 comma 2 let's see
5 Plus 5 is 10 squared is 100 times 1/2
is 50 52 not 2 so we can rule this one
out as well so it looks pretty clear
that this is we could use this
expression to define the interval X is
greater than or equal to 3 and less than
not less than or equal to it's not
defined at seven so we could use this
for this interval right over here so
let's go back to the actual exercise and
so we said this one for this interval
right over here and let's make sure that
we that we got it right so check our
answer and we did